le stationnement devient de plus en plus
difficiles à guyancourt récemment
certains administrés ont reçu des
contraventions alors qu'ils étaient
garés devant chez eux comme à leur
habitude des changements qu'ils ne
comprennent pas ils n'ont pas hésité à
protester sur les réseaux sociaux les
voitures garées dans les rues de bouvier
ont toutes été verbalisé ce matin alors
que la réglementation ou le plan de
voirie n'a pas changé depuis plus de dix
ans j'avoue ne pas comprendre être
sidéré par cette démarche
j'ai reçu ça aujourd'hui sur ma voiture
au boulevard mozart à guyancourt
merci monsieur le maire où est la
solidarité en cette période de crise une
pétition a également été lancés par les
habitants du boulevard mozart les place
devant nos maisons ont été supprimées et
nous ne pouvons nous garer devant notre
domicile sous peine de verbalisation
nous vous demandons de réétudier votre
réglementation concernant les places de
stationnement boulevard mozart c'est
bien à la suite des différents
aménagements de la voirie mais aussi de
l'arrivée de nouveaux immeubles que le
manque de places de stationnement s'est
fait ressentir
y'a plus en plus de construction la plus
en plus de monter rêve moi je me
souviens quand on est réussie en 83 éric
deschamps face aux sollicitations et aux
plaintes des habitants la mairie a
décidé d'engager une grande concertation
autour du stationnement
la première étape est en cours puisque
je vais sur l'ensemble des sites
j'ai dénombré jusqu'à présent 32 sites
que je vais rencontrer ces rencontres
devraient avoir lieu d'ici l'été
parallèlement un cabinet d'études
spécialisé va être mandatés c'est
important d'avoir un regard extérieur de
professionnels pour nous dire aussi où
nous confirmait nos intentions et je
referai en retour j'espère avant l'été
sinon plus tard à la rentrée pour voir
les mesures à prendre d'ici à la fin de
la concertation la mairie a demandé à la
police municipale de limiter la
verbalisation aux situations
véritablement dangereuse ou
contraignantes